[Music]
what is up everybody
Anna Mack here for anime uproar and in
this video we will be discussing one of
the most requested topic in our comment
sections and on social media and that is
how did some of the students in class
1-a get into that class in the first
place especially since some students
with incredible quirks like heat oh
sheesh in Seoul failed to get into class
1a or 1b and ended up in class 1c
joining me for this epic and highly
requested discussion is my good friend
NOx Taku hey Knox what's happening space
fanboys since we know the NOx loves
being just a disembodied voice I decided
to represent him with this lovely
figurine of saber from the faith series
you don't mind right nuts wait what
before we get started I want to give a
quick thank you to this place comm for
sending me this awesome metal poster
featuring the winning design from our
create your own my hero academia
character contest display calm has
agreed to sponsor these contests which
will be happening on a regular basis on
our channel by sending me and the winner
the winning design as a metal poster for
free Congrats again to gravity falls for
winning the first contest and I think
guzo money did an amazing job bringing
the idea to light if you want to enter
future contests for a chance to have
your idea be brought to life by a
professional artist and then send to you
for free as a metal poster be sure to
follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime healthpro and if you want to see
other amazing designs that display calm
makes feel free to check them out link
is in the description and if you use our
promo code you can get 20% off and
without further adue knucks are you
ready to begin
oh yeah let's do it shiro I mean Hana
Mac wow that was weird and by the way
everybody Knox loves to call himself
Lord knocks on door but let's spice this
up and let's start calling him Knox
Turiya instead if you want to help me
troll Knox check out his latest video
link is in the description and type in
hashtag Knox turiya in the comments and
without further ado let's do this
wait no stop so we saw how Deku or choco
EDA and Oh
got in Baku blasted his way through the
competition
Todoroki and Momo got in on
recommendations and some members of
class 1a have quirks that can pretty
easily lend themselves to crushing the
exam so we have Mina who could use acid
to destroy the robots dank he can
electrocute them Kirishima can just
smash them and obviously Takayama can
use dark shadow to smash them we also
have our boy Seto who can use his
spider-man asked abilities to get great
rescue points or to deactivate the
robots because we actually found out
that wrote the robots had switches that
could be used to deactivate them for
those whose quirks are more stealth and
agility based rather than raw power base
we also know that based on that based on
Sarah's abilities we can imagine that
too you would have a pretty easy time
jumping around the robots and
deactivating them with her tongue and
Jiro could use earphone jack to hack the
robots and take them out so I think that
all of those kind of makes sense Knox
would you agree yes I would agree with
most except for Seto he clearly does a
lot of damage you know with his flexing
and his tape and stuff quite the
powerhouse there so you'd think that he
could have just you think that Sarah
could have just used the raw power well
no but the Flex tape meme is far too
good to have wasted it and not say that
he could do a lot of damage fine
I guess everything has to be a meme with
NOx you could never be super serious
with NOx
well yeah I think Sarah could just use
all the abilities that he has to move
around the urban landscape like
spider-man right like he could move
around the buildings deactivate the
robots rescue people so I feel like
Sarah's quirk is definitely really well
suited for the urban environment yeah
but if you wore long sleeves he would be
useless correct correct
he cannot wear a jacket or any sort of
it's a very important point us
definitely many people do not realise
this flaw in his character he is ever
cold in the winter horse yeah that's the
sacrifice you have to make for being a
purl tape hero it's just the way it goes
so Knox you would agree with all the
guys I mentioned that's 14 of them that
it makes sense how they got in and some
of them we know how they got in because
we
in the enemy yep pretty straightforward
okay so that still leaves six students
that were not sure exactly how they
passed the entrance exam and got into
class 1a so let's examine those guys I'm
down first up let's talk about missile
Shoji we know as quark do plie arms
allows them to duplicate his arms and
other parts of his body right so pretty
interesting query quite the handy course
yes Andy good I like it but how does
although sometimes it's a bit eerie I
see what you're doing there but anyway
uh anyways uh tell me then Knox how does
disability which is unique and
interesting applied to passing the
entrance exam which requires destroying
robot village so initially my
consideration was he can gross out the
robots but then I realized that there
was a flaw in that strategy and grossing
out robots would not score a lot of
points so that aside he is pretty strong
I mean physically powerful we have seen
him have you know quite a few decent
feats throughout the show he can carry
like 50 people no problem I think that's
actually right because his power
according to the official guidebook is 5
out of 5 so 5 out of 5 person on power
so he definitely could have used that
raw power to his advantage smashed the
robots with his multiple arms and such
he's pretty Swift too he's not that slow
he could have just racked up enough
points with small robots and fast yes I
think with metal shoji it does make
sense okay moving on to machine Oh Oh
Jude oh the guy with the big tail oh
that guy definitely one of the most
ingenious characters in the entire
series don't you love how he sacrificed
himself for deku and decker didn't use
what he sacrificed himself for noble but
yes true and Deku still won so the
sacrifice was completely meaningless
yeah who needs friends and then you can
have a plot that makes believe you have
friends but yes so odious quirk seems to
be just having a tail like that's all it
is but it is a pretty handy tail
so how do you think knocks that he would
have aced this entrance exam so funnily
enough I also think he's a brute-force
hero
I mean he's trained in martial arts in
his karate kung-fu thing oh and he's
powerful on his own right at least
stronger than your average guy and his
tail looks like a big penis coming out
of his ass which is pretty pretty sick
so with all those reasons in mind that
note those reasons in mind I do believe
he could have just darted around taking
out the small ones kind of like Shoji
yeah so he has a very strong tail tail
knocks tail now and he can we know that
he can use it to like propel himself
upward or forward so he can use it to be
more maneuverable and faster and I'm
sure that it has a lot of strength so
you can use it to like a Smasher robot
deactivate him whatever so yeah
definitely that is how he could have
passed the test but here's the real
question here's the real question what
does he do with that tail when he needs
to go to sleep that's a great question I
was gonna say masturbate but then I
remembered that no it's actually a tail
he got me maybe he sleeps upside down
hanging by the tail like um like a
monkey I was thinking of that that'll be
cool that would be cool but yeah I'd you
know definitely a strong guy so moving
on next up is Toru hagakure
the Invisible Girl how did she pass the
physical exam the entrance exam where
you have to defeat big massive robots
well if we're relying on the power memes
here we didn't see her not kill any
robots right well we didn't see her at
all
exactly that's how good she was at
killing robots because she's the
Invisible Girl well that was the point
that was the joke we didn't see her not
kill robots even the teachers couldn't
prove she didn't kill robots yeah I
guess he couldn't prove it I don't know
yeah I don't know how they were even
monitoring her like um to see how many
points she got especially if she didn't
have anything on she just like took her
clothes off it's like I don't know what
happened so that's a good point there I
didn't think of that to be honest you
don't know what she did hug the teachers
were there and like a big rule
entering everyone how could even see
total that's exactly how she passed they
were thinking selves but we can't fail
the poor girl I mean after all we don't
know if she didn't kill all the robots
how many people someone had to
maybe she saved like a village they they
had no proofs otherwise so to avoid a
lawsuit I believe that they passed okay
but to be fair this is like a fake
environment battle arena she's not
saving real people here but okay to be
to try to be fair here we did learn from
horikoshi later on from an interview I
believe or from one of those questions
sections in the manga that the students
who don't have battle based quirks had
the option of sneaking up on the robot
and hitting a switch that was hidden on
the robot and deactivating him that way
and they would get points for that did
you know that no I did not but you
mentioned in the intro and I was like
damn yes so a lot of people who look at
how Toto might have passed say well
because she's invisible she can just
sneak up on the robots but this only
works if the robots don't have infrared
sensors right because if they can
exactly yeah there's no reason why the
robots couldn't see err yes so if they
had if they could detect body heat then
they still would have seen Toru unless
their sensors were literally just you
know cameras in which case she could
have snuck up on them there were cameras
but that means people must have been
controlling the robots yeah so it
depends either the robots were had
sensors that didn't look at body heat or
people were controlling them and they
were just using their own eyes but I
will raise you this toggle raise the
stakes here Knox I think Toto could have
used her light refraction technique to
fry the robot sensors so that's the
ability where she basically can use the
Solar Flare technique from Dragonball
that Tian ya mastered and then Crillon
uses kind of like blinds them with
delight by refracting the light from her
body so I'm not exactly sure what you're
referring to to be completely honest she
could do that oh yes so this was just
recently in the anime she can basically
kind of reflect the light from her body
into like a beam almost that kind of
blinds you like so she become
all of a sudden really bright what was
that in the last was that in the manga
tube yes it was in the manga and he was
recently in the anime during the
provisional exam license argh damn Wow
that makes absolutely no sense but okay
I mean it could make sense honestly
because if her body is just invisible
yeah but if it's invisible because it's
reflecting light in such a way that she
looks invisible but she's actually still
there then she could technically reflect
the light in a different way to make it
like oke to make an interest a sort of
solar flare but if that's the case then
it's kind of like if she can control how
her body reflects light and how come she
can't become visible because that's not
how it works and it just doesn't make
sense that she can shoot solar flares
she doesn't shoot them she just becomes
really really bright knucks and it hurts
your eyes okay
okay I'll give this one to you fair
enough fight so technically maybe she
fried the robot sensors maybe she just
snuck up on them we don't know but it's
possible right so she could have passed
some ways so okay let's move on let's
move on next up is our boy do you know
who I mean I hope you're saving me meta
for last because he's our real boy I'm
talking about Minoru minute Onix AKA i
said that that's exactly what I just
said Minato mean it also known as crazy
little Baba [ __ ] that is correct and
yeah so how did me know Luminita this is
the question that I get the most by the
way in the comments and stuff he brought
how didn't mean it to get into the best
school do you a get into class 1-a
so I have several theorems as to how
he's actually passed however I fart I
find it far more plausible that with his
masterful peeping ability he got some
dirt on the school and he blackmailed
them into letting him pass so you think
that he might have gotten naked pictures
of midnight and said I will release
these to the world if you don't pass no
he meant to go for midnight but we don't
know what he saw in cement haces room
and we don't want to know yeah man that
is
that would be an interesting sight to
see cement oz in his full nude cement
glory I mean this is a fair theory it
would be like an Easter Island head Mina
is an evil genius so he could have done
this on a more I guess less
conspiratorial note he could have used
his balls to make the robot stick to the
ground right because some of the robots
had wheels if I remember correctly so
you could have just thrown a bunch of
balls at them until they stuck to the
ground and then potentially snuck up on
them and he activated them or maybe just
the fact that they can't move actually
counts as the points anyway right yeah
well it's definitely good as far as
stalling them and saving people that's
for sure yes now one thing that I'm
wondering it you know how his balls
bounce off of him even though they stick
to everyone else if he could master this
technique and just like bounce from one
ball up to the other and hold from one
wall to another or something using the
balls he could be like better than
spider-man he could be like moving
around like he could be like like he
could be the next Oh might and by the
way someone mentioned that in a previous
video on our crazy anime theories
someone's like can you please make a
video about the fact that Moneta is
actually stronger than all mites before
I think that in the future it could turn
out that meaneth has actually the main
character volcano here and deku was just
red herring the whole time what do you
think I'm not exactly sure what you mean
by in the future I was always I always
okay well see see it's already happening
we don't even know it but it's happening
moving on
I think Minetta has made his case moving
on to Ricky dosa toe aka our boy sugar
man aka diabetes a diabetes hero this
actually is a pretty big mystery to me
to be honest because okay so what does
his quirk do if he consumes 10 grams of
sugar his strength increases five times
but this only lasts for a few minutes
and if he keeps consuming sugar to stay
strong longer what happens is he has
like a sugar crash make sense and then
he becomes sleepy and it also he can't
think straight his cognitive ability
just like declines severely so how can
he use this quirk which is so temporary
and has a big drawback to pass this
physical exam I think he found two big
robots standing next to each other and
with his luscious thick lips he gave
them each a [ __ ] hauling them into a
false sense of security
then downs five packets of sugar and
smashed the two of them at the same time
and since they were big-ass robots got
him to pass the exam I don't know I
don't know what this [ __ ] your speak
of is but a their robots NOx and B this
is a family-friendly Channel robots need
to be lubed and I apologize alright so
I'll throw another sort of complication
into this for you NOx because according
to the official stats Rokita sato speed
is only 1 out of 5 so he is extremely
slow so how can he evade these robots
how can he destroy them in such a short
period of time ah
because after giving the blow job in
destroying the first two robots all the
other robots feared his presence to such
a tremendous degree they clearly went
after different opponents they did not
want to deal with diabetes hope diabetes
Hulk is his true hero name I think I
could have totally alien queen he should
be diabetes Hawk I agree with you on
that if we had to have less [ __ ] in
our answer I guess the only thing that
makes sense in this case is that he
found a bunch of robots he quickly took
a bunch of sugar and just like within
two or three minutes smashed a bunch of
them and that's how he passed before he
had to take more sugar and feel the
negative consequences of his quirk
agreed agreed although I would have
included the blow job thing because I
thought it added pizzazz to his story of
course you did
alright then we have one more person
left and this person the hardest of them
all this person already got an entire
video on this channel so I talked about
it a bit but I want to talk about this
with you in particular that person of
course is Koji Koda and his work and a
voice
also known as bugga for all hell yeah
the meme spreads it is it is infectious
so okay talking about Kota we know that
his quirk allows him to communicate with
and control animals right but as I
mentioned in that previous video there
are not gonna be many animals in a
battle arena that is artificially
constructed meaning that no one actually
lives there there are no food sources
you know garbage whatever so you're not
gonna find necessarily rats there or
raccoons or animals that could like chew
through the wiring so I think that that
option where he just gets a bunch of
animals and rats and stuff to destroy
the robots won't necessarily work this
is true I believe so as well and I have
my theorem but I believe you should
first say what you were thinking and
what was in your theory fine also
another option is insects but can
insects really hurt a robot I don't know
then we also had birds but birds for
birds to destroy robots they would have
to like basically kamikaze into the
robots killing hundreds of birds in the
process if not thousands I don't think
that our boy Koji would be up for that
and if he would that I feel like he was
definitely some kind of villain so
they're Birds I mean I like birds as
much as the next guy but at the same
time I've watched Hitchcock those
bastards are dangerous sucking [ __ ]
knocks Hitchcock's birds were not was
not a documentary I just want to say
that birds are living creatures you know
you got to respect that bro and someone
like Koji Kota who loves animals and
communicates with them you would think
respects Birds but the other option is
that you know you said that minute I
might have blackmailed at this the
school I mean how about Koji Kota
manipulating naisu the principal of the
school who happens to be an extremely
rare case of an animal with a quirk in
order to just get him in and therefore
the test doesn't matter he just gets in
because the principal has no choice but
to do it and as you could see from his
composure
he's totally up for the challenge hey
Koji Kota seems like such a nice guy
loves his mother loves animals loves
nature super shy and also he manipulated
Nessa to get him into class one day and
he's actually the you a traitor that
would be pretty nuts that would be
absolutely but you didn't like my
magnetic conspiracy theory so can we try
to go
around yours okay sure I want you to
counter argue my big cogeco de
conspiracy theory well I'm not gonna
counter argue that one there's no proofs
against it kind of like invisible girl
he can't prove she didn't kill the
robots but with cogeco de it's far far
simpler than you've even imagined
because there was one bird in the
vicinity in particular that could have
absolutely destroyed the robots are you
talking about the chicken of Darkness I
am talking about the chicken of Darkness
himself he could have controlled Tokyo
Yami to destroy the robots and that
would be sick but I don't think that's
true because totally I mean while he
looks like a bird he's not really a bird
just like to you well she looks like a
frog she's not really a frog so I think
that he can only at least I'm assuming
that he can only at control real Panem I
don't know the doujins between Koji and
- you may disagree hi that's not my area
expertise Knox I will leave that to you
but I just think that he would have to
control a real animal but it just so
happens that one of the most extreme
cases of an animal actually having a
quirk it's extremely rare happens to be
the principle the whole school pretty
big coincidence and then you're thinking
how did coach you get in I don't know
pretty big coincidence I don't know at
this point it's basically the most
logical theory how he actually passed I
mean aside from plotholes of course
because as we know there's no plot holes
in heroic Damien either that or mass
bird murder I know he doesn't seem like
the genocide type maybe well I think
that now we have basically come up with
all the most logical and 100% foolproof
and definitely not meme answers to
everyone on how they got in we've
answered everyone's questions everyone
will be completely satisfied now right
Knox yeah the comments won't have any
salt and then whatsoever I guarantee it
comment sections never have solved
absolutely everyone's gonna be like
these guys are hundred percent right I
don't even need to comment I don't even
need to say anything because these guys
covered of course that's not gonna
happen guys but that's okay feel free to
leave in the comments your feedback how
do you think that some of these guys
passed the entrance exam
NIEM answers are definitely accepted
meme is definitely accepted and of
course if you wanna give us more
feedback for future videos follow both
me and Knox on Twitter at anime prefer
me and at Knox underscore Taku for you
right knucks yep
links in the description if you enjoyed
this type of video where we just kind of
talk and have fun and totally not
trigger anyone let us know in the
comments leave a like all that good
stuff subscribe to this channel
subscribe to Knox's channel and until
next time Knox is definitely going to
not make a joke about my outro SIA space
cowboys and stay weird fan
[Music]